hi everyone Welcome to our session my
name is bashak and together my colleague
Maria we will talk about model
traceability and reproducibility
um before we dive into the problem and
solution let's have a look at what type
of organization we work at we are
working at ahold Delhi it is one of the
largest food retailers in the world it
has 19 brands in different continents
it's a very complex structure as many
other companies of this size
Maria and I we are working at Global
Support Office it is an essential unit
that supports brand from different
angles it can be legal it can be Finance
it can be HR we are in the digital
department and we support brands from
data science perspective some brands do
have very Advanced Data science
capability they have big teams some
brands do not have any data science or
envelopes capability so we help those
Brands who are in need of either data
science or envelopes help envelops need
so um while we started um working at aho
Del heisei we started also observing
some issues that are happening in the
brands
um that we support
because things are not always going
right examples we have a personalized
offer model it gives a weekly
personalized offers to our customers
based on their purchases previous
purchases one thing we realized all of
our customers got very expensive Gene
offer not really relevant to everyone
and we couldn't really identify what was
the reason because we were not able to
go back to the model artifact or the
code that is responsible for that
prediction
another example we have a cross-sell
model running on our e-commerce websites
it's a real-time inference model when
our customers are shopping while they
add new products to their baskets this
model uh suggests them to to add more
items
one week our customers kept seeing only
plastic bags as suggestions at their
baskets during their online shopping and
we actually couldn't understand why we
wanted to go back to the pre to the code
and the model artifact that is used it
took us a lot of time and effort to
investigate this problem and all these
things can affect our customer journey
in a negative way
so if we frame the problem when things
are going fine it's all peace but when
we uh when things are going wrong
um it would be very difficult to fix the
box it would take so much time
um it would also take so much time to
find the relevant code for prediction to
actually investigate further and if
we're not happy with the current model
it was not really possible to revert
back to the previous model as we were
not able to trace back so as a solution
we set
let's Implement traceability and let's
embed it in our design
so what is traceability traceability is
for any given machine learning model
deployment it is possible to look up
unambiguously the corresponding code and
comet on git the infrastructure used for
training and serving the environment
used for training and serving
corresponding job run and the Machine
learning model artifact so we wanted to
implement this in our solution design
foreign
but um traceability is not limited to
any certain tool or any certain solution
architecture for each component there
are multiple tools multiples of software
available in the market
we just needed to collect what we have
in our Organization for Version Control
CI CD orchestration model registry
container registry compute and serving
so as you see there are many examples
that can be used for each component in
our organization
we have the followings so we use GitHub
as our Version Control we use GitHub
actions as our CI CD
we use databricks workflows to
orchestrate our jobs we use ml flow for
model registry we use Azure container
registry to register our Docker images
and we use databricks jobs and clusters
as our compute power and we use Azure
kubernetes services for serving our
real-time inference-based models
so with this we this is the our solution
design we have a data Lake which is blob
storage and we get our code from Version
Control which is GitHub and we put it in
our databricks compute power as a job
it's a training job and we store our
artifact after training is completed in
our model registry ml flow and we create
our Docker image with the model model
artifact and then we deploy our apis
using kubernetes for serving purposes so
this is our solution design
and traceability is implemented on top
of that
so what we do is we connect we connect
GitHub commit hash databricks run ID and
mouthful of run ID to each prediction
generated by the model at each API
request
before we dive into the solution I also
like to highlight that we have two
different environments we have
pre-production and production they are
the same architecture with different
workspaces from pre-production
environment we only have read access to
production data
uh which allows our data scientists to
develop their models with real data this
is again for our company for our
organization it can be different for in
each organization to have how many
different environments or workspaces for
cost related reasons we kept it as two
environments
so Maria will dive into traceability by
Design in five steps
I want to highlight first um that we use
databricks as a main compute for
training our models
and when we look at databricks workflows
databrix workflows just as any
orchestrator you have like Azure data
Factory or top functions it can be
defined in Json format so any database
job is defined as Json so if you go to
database workspace and click on any job
and look at Job details you can see a
representation of that this is important
because we can use it to pass certain
things to this job Json definition that
can help us further in doing
traceability by Design
so if we are looking at all these steps
that we mentioned
um step one would be how how can we make
it as a j available inside the python
scripted runs on databricks
so to catch git sha we use GitHub
actions it is available in GitHub
actions then we we have that as
environment variable and it have actions
and we use this information to modify
our job definition
at inside GitHub actions so basically
the output of it would look like git sha
passed as environment variable
inside our job which will make it
available for us to catch it and pass it
further
so the step two would be how to make
vanity available inside the python
script that runs in databricks so that
is not that trivial there are multiple
ways of doing so so for example if you
work with databricks you are familiar
with DB utils Library most probably
um that can be used to catch from ID
inside a python script that's running on
databricks but we don't want to use
dbutus because we want our script to be
runnable anywhere the utils is only
available on databricks so locally it's
not possible to use it unless you use
some kind of connector to databricks but
if you just want to run some tests you
would have to adjust your code
um a lot and we don't want our code to
be adjusted to run on any environment so
it should be the same code that can run
pretty much anywhere so
um then we looked what what are the
other possibilities
so databricks provides a nice feature
called task parameter variables
so these are the variables that can be
passed to your databricks job definition
and those will be filled at the moment
of run
so the examples of such task parameter
variables are job ID so it's in the
unique identifier assigned to a job run
ID unique identifier Center job run if
you have a job with multiple tasks then
you need to have parent run IDs as
unique identifier for run of your job
and there is also very black task key
and there are more things that can be
used to task parameter variables for
example if you have a secret Scopes
defined in databricks those can also be
passed as task parameter variables
so um because we pass geophagy and
ranergy as python parameters then those
can be readable inside our python script
that we run
and next question would be when we have
this python script and where run ID is
available guitar is available we need to
register a model in the mail flow so
that it can be retrieved later on by
specific vanity
is pretty much unique So guitar is not
that important then but it is important
for 3C BLD so that we know what code
exactly don't have to look it up but it
is efficient to retrieve it just by run
ID
so um as I mentioned raniji and joburg
is now available as python parameters
for your python tasks so it can be
retrieved using argument parser
so basically run ID and job ID are now
available
inside the python script and then we
want to tag our
run in ml flow
by using this information so we create
some tags when we register the model it
would be a commit hash or job ID run ID
also ml4190 which is different from
littlebox run ID things like experiment
ID and maybe some extra things you want
to pass
so we use
register model function to pass those
tags that are defined here
and when we do so then we can go back to
the databricks workspace and look how
our models are registered and then you
see that all this information is
available there the commit has job ID
run into experimentality and experiment
may be passed in this case
which makes it actually searchable
uh which brings us to The Next Step
we want to embed the model into a Docker
image so we need to download it first in
our GitHub actions to be able to pass it
to the image at the build at the build
stage
of course you could argue why do we need
to embed the image into the docker why
do we need to embed the model into the
docker image well in our case
um it's the connectivity from kubernetes
to ml flow is not always straightforward
due to security
limitation due to security
um restrictions but
um
it can be done differently if you have a
different use case so in our case we
want to always embed model into the
docker image
so how do we do so
um as I mentioned because we have
certain tags like databricks run ID
available for all our models that we
register it makes it searchable so in
mouth flow client you can search for
model version that is corresponding to a
particular ranadine and then with
modular artifact repository you can
actually download this artifacts using
this version that you just have found so
it makes it possible to download the
artifact in GitHub actions and pass it
to the docker image at the docker build
step
so
um then when we have a Docker image
available in Docker registry we also tag
it with Git sha and run ID
we want to make also gitsha and manage
the available inside the docker that is
used to serve our API and provides a
response that contains guitar and run ID
as well
so to deploy API to kubernetes it's
possible to pass environment variables
in the deployment manifest so deployment
manifest is also modified used in GitHub
actions where running didn't get cji
available
and we pass this information to
um to the Manifest and then when it's
deployed those are retrievable inside
our app using as environment variables
so basically we then return when we
return the prediction we also return
this extra information
you may argue why why do you need it why
do we need to to do it this way that
it's available in response body so in
our particular use case our apis are not
faced directly by the clients they are
used by front-end team and it is very
handy to know for them in case we do a b
testing then the API the call will
produce different responses with getting
git sha and run ID which will be
different from model and for model B so
if they start to see a weird performance
from
one of the models they can tell us
exactly what Trinity was producing those
weird predictions and we can fix it so
it makes it much easier to communicate
with the team
and makes our life indent much easier
because we implemented all these five
steps and everything is traceable from
at the beginning to the end it also
actually makes it very easy to do the
rollbacks
so the rollbacks in our case is
triggered by triggered manually on
workflow dispatch because that's
something that you don't do that often
anyways and that's something that you
typically do manually
so
um if
um you can then roll back to the
previous to a specific Docker image
because we know what runidy and what git
sha it has in text
and if no input is provided a specific
Docker image we can always retrieve the
previous Docker image because we know
what version it is in ml4 that we use
currently let's say version three we
know that the previous will be version 2
and version 2 we know what git tag and
what running it has and because those
information is available as tags in our
Docker image we know the docker image to
use here so in this case running back it
becomes very easy
so um to come back basically to our
solution for traceability there are
these five steps that go
um from Version Control in GitHub to
compute in databricks then we store
artifacts in model registry when we have
this available we embed it into Docker
image and store it in dock registry and
then we deploy the kubernetes and
because those
variables are available environment
variables we can also access it in our
app and provide it in response body
thank you for your attention that was
our presentation on traceability and
reproducibility and looking forward for
your questions
thank you very much for this informative
presentation thank you
um
we are more than happy to take any
questions
yes
thank you
there are no questions yet so you can
give it
well I can imagine that
many people have uh comparable
experience with
that is hard to trace things back
anything that is quite helpful
and how do we manage the storage
archival of the docker image there is a
question
um so what do we mean by this question
exactly so we store we store all Docker
images in our ACR and there is also
cleaning procedure that we want to
implement at a later stage does that all
Docker images will be removed and only a
last three or so I kept
that's something that we are planning to
implement that is currently not
implemented but I think it's important
to have this cleaning procedure for your
Docker images and for all your artifacts
because it costs you storage and it
costs you money in the end if you don't
do so the same goes for logs
yeah ACR is azure container registry and
uh so far our models are trained either
weekly or daily
um which is now still manageable to keep
the images
also we have another question
and do you store retrieve the metadata
for traceability in a structured way
so I'm not sure what is meant by
structured way so the way how we store
the metadata uh
well the metadata is basically the text
I guess the tax for the uh for the model
artifacts
so those
are quite easy to retrieve using this
malfo client
but we don't store any information like
this in
now in a database or anything like that
or in well in the logs we have some of
this information as well but it's not
stored in the table or database or
anything like that
we log our response
um with prediction and with necessary
tags like run ID and git hash when we
have
API request so those are locked
yeah and we need this information also
for a b testing because we do when we do
a b testing we need to know what
requests and responses were
corresponding to what model and then we
know then we can connect it back to the
data in the data Lake and
what Malone did better than the other
great thank you for answering this
question
we still have some time for other
questions
maybe as a feature work we also want to
implement certain traceability on data
versioning because we retrieve data from
our data Lake and it is a data Engineers
responsibility to put data there and
make it available but we do not have yet
the control on with data which data
version is used
in our model so that that that's our
next step to also have visibility and
traceability on data versioning
few more questions came so far
but we still have time
[Music]
maybe we can tell in general what we are
trying to achieve in our organization so
um we are part of the central unit as we
were explaining we are part of a general
support office
and we see that a lot of different
brands have the same needs so the
solution we presented
um that's something that is implemented
in reusable cicd pipelines that pretty
much everyone can use
and they are importable workflows that
we provide as a service to the brands
and those Brands can also contribute to
what we do so basically distressibility
that's something that can be implemented
if someone has a notebook a databricks
notebook we could make it traceable
within an hour
based on the pipelines that we provide
okay thank you
there is a question
um yes so the question is whether we
also thinking to equip data science team
to take ownership of the envelope's work
so that's exactly the purpose of what we
are doing so the pipelines that we
provide data scientists have all the
power to do deployment themselves
of course there are some guard rails so
they have to create a pull request and
follow all the processes that are um
that everyone knows from software
development
but they have all the power to deploy
themselves so basically they don't need
machine learning Engineers to do this
for them and we try to empower data
scientists and that's the goal of what
we do because the brands that we work
with they don't have their own machine
learning Engineers often
and we don't want anyone to be dependent
on us because we need to support a lot
of different teams a lot of different
projects
which means
yeah that's the only way for us to give
the ownership to the data science teams
so what we are trying to achieve is more
to provide them a golden path
um which is basically how to do certain
things how to deploy models how to make
sure traceability is in place
um and we provide those tools to data
science teams within the brands that we
support
which also makes things more reusable
that way the data science teams
themselves can actually deploy models
thank you for the question
awesome thank you for answering
yes so friends are sharing we're using
in from
um well not really so we have different
brands and there is also a central
platform team for some of the brands and
those have reusable infra deployment
so basically the infrastructure is put
in the very same way for all those
brands on the platform
and because it's so shared and it's all
set up in the same way the workspace is
shared typically across multiple
projects
and we have organization organizational
secrets in GitHub that they use for our
service principle credentials are stored
so um in in that sense it may it is made
super easy for data scientists to use
those PowerPoints without without
thinking about any of these
technicalities behind it
so they not really share uh the
infrastructure but the infrastructure
are deployed for each brand in the same
way so they actually have all these
components in common
which makes our pipelines reusable of
course because they are implemented in a
certain way to uh create interaction
between different components